ζήσαμε παραπληροφόρησην έντονί κυρίος τους γωνείς ζήσαμε ναπιλές ζήσαμε παρά πολλά είδαμε και γραπτά και
επιστολές θα μας επηρεάσουν το σχολείο μας θαδηλητηριάσουν το σχολείο μας έληξε για μας το
θέμα κάναμε τις ενημερώσεις που χρειάζετου και επιαποφασίσαμε και σε ένα καινούριο χώρών να κάνουμε
το σχολείο ξέρετε για μέναν οι σωστεί απόφαση να ξέρεις και πότε κάνει σπίσω για
το καλό πιού δεν δεν παίζεται εκεί ιδική μου υφίμη η φιμη του υπουργείου ιπιος
κερδίζεις δεν είναι τέτοιας φύσεις το θέμα είναι ιον ε το καλύτερο για αυτά τα
παιδιά και εκεί θα κινδύνευα αυτά τα παιδιά ο πότε αυτά τα πέντε πεδάκια τα
παίρνουμ κάπου αλλού σήμερα στην κύπρον έχουμε την παιδία πουαρμόζιση μια χώρα της επρωβακής ενώσης
όχι ξεκάθαρα όχι τα αποδελέσματα όλον των διεθνών ρευνών δείχνουν μέχρι και το κοστρία που
αναλάβαμε έρευνα που βγήκε νχτές πάλι ότι είμαστε στον πάτο εγίνε για αυτό τον λόγο
που κάνουμε ότι κάνουμε μέσα από το πρόγραμμα διακυβέρνησης αλλάζουμε τα δεδομένα είτε αρέσειται δεν
αραίσει σε μπορλούσ αυτό θα πρέπει να αλλάξουμε πρακτικές αναλητικά προγράμμματα αξιολόγηση του εκπαιδευτικού ο
τρόπος που διδάσκουμε είναι εστεχνολογίες δεχδεν μπορούν να λείπουν για από ένα σύχρονο σχολείο λκαι
μάλιστα σε έναν εκπαιδευτικό σύστημα να επιτρέψετε μου το οποίο στοιχίζει πάρα πολύ και στιχίζει
για πολλούς και διάφορους λόγους δικαιόμαστε να έχουμε να παιτήσεις για καλύτερα αποτελέσματα για όλα
τα παιδιά θελάς ρωτήσω να μου πεί τε ένα ν επισόδιο μια καταγγελία που έφτασεν
κοντά σας απόμάθει τη ν απομαθήτρια η οποία συγκλώνησε την υπουρο παπιαναι δεν ήταν καταγγελια
μπορώ να ανακαλέσω στη μνύμη μου περιστατικός ι το οποίον νήμου παρούσαν δυστυχώς και ήταν
η πρώτη φορά που βάζαμε τα θέματα της εξοαλικής διαπαιδαγόγηση